- This video is sponsored by Squarespace.
Come on, there it goes, one, two, three.
(papers shuffling)
Let's do this.
It's 2004, the Super Bowl.
Jessica Simpson just
announced the beginning
of the halftime show.
The show starts with Janet
Jackson and then Nelly
and his crew riding out on a red truck
to sing a song about it
being very hot in here
and telling women to...
♪ Take off all your clothes ♪
♪ I am getting so hot ♪
- Then Puff Daddy
or P. Diddy or just Diddy
I guess or Sean Combs,
or whatever you want to call him.
And then the finale of the halftime show,
back to Janet Jackson but this time,
in the final moments
of this whole, big show
superstar Justin Timberlake
comes onto stage.
Him and Janet Jackson
perform one of Timberlake's
most popular songs, "Rock Your Body."
The final line of that song says, quote,
"Bet I'll have you naked
by the end of this song."
It feels really weird
to say that in quotes.
Anyway, as that last line approaches,
Justin Timberlake moves
close to Janet Jackson
to prepare for that final
line and then this happens.
♪ Naked by the end of this song ♪
(crowd cheering)
(soft instrumental music)
- [Johnny] Okay, hold on, instant replay.
And yes, I'm blurring
this because I have to.
It's YouTube and I just
have to blur this moment.
Justin Timberlake reaches
over and pulls the breast cup
of Janet Jackson's shirt, ripping it off
to reveal her breast for
just over a half a second
to an audience of millions of people.
This moment was a spark
that lit a wildfire.
- Was it planned, Janet?
- Tell us exactly what happened.
- Last week's shameful halftime display.
(upbeat pop music)
- We love giving y'all
something to talk about.
- Closer, let me inch...
(men shouting and laughing)
- Publicity stunt.
(sighs) Okay.
I was really young when this all happened,
but I have been deep in
it reading newspapers
and stuff from that time
and I didn't realize
that this half a second of exposed breast
became an inflection point in TV
and internet history, in American history.
Suddenly the whole world
wanted to talk about it,
to scrutinize it, to
find out what happened
and why, who's to blame.
The founder of YouTube
actually said in an interview
that one of the reasons he started YouTube
was because of this moment
because so many people
wanted to rewatch a
video of what went down
and they couldn't find
it because back then
there was no YouTube,
there was no Facebook,
there was no Twitter.
So he literally invented
YouTube to solve the problem.
People wanted to see this, to
scrutinize it, to look at it.
The internet searches for
Janet Jackson went bonkers.
There was such a massive influx of people
searching the internet
that Janet's webpage,
which back then was just
like a fan page, crashed.
Like, if you go back to look
at the archives of the internet
there's just like a black spot in the days
after the Super Bowl because literally
there was so much traffic
that it just crashed the site.
Janet Jackson was under this microscope.
Everybody wanted to have an opinion.
The whole thing spurred a debate
about how families should be
able to watch the Super Bowl
without being exposed to lewd,
sexually provocative content.
♪ So take off all your clothes ♪
♪ My hookers all drinking at Hollywood ♪
- No, no, no, not that stuff, that's fine.
There was a boob.
A real-life boob for 1/2 a second on TV.
That's what we're talking
about, stay focused.
The White House issued a
statement on the topic.
Congress had a hearing about this.
The FCC, which is the place
that regulates broadcasters
here in the US launched an investigation
into whether or not CBS,
who broadcast the Super
Bowl, was in on it.
- Last week's shameful halftime
display at the Super Bowl
You knew it was going to happen, right?
You did know what was going to happen?
- No, I didn't.
- [David] You didn't
know it was gonna happen?
- Janet Jackson's explanation
for this whole thing
is that it was a stunt but it
went wrong, it went too far.
- It was supposed to
kind of happen like that,
but what actually happened wasn't,
I wasn't supposed to come
out of it the way that I did.
- Janet said that what
was supposed to happen
is that Justin Timberlake rips this off
and there was supposed
to be a bra underneath
and it was supposed to
be kind of provocative
but not like, full breast.
- It was very embarrassing for me
to have so many people see.
- But people didn't believe this.
With the media discussion
and the congressional hearing
and the FCC investigation people started
to make their own opinions
about what they believed actually happened
and who was to blame.
- Tonight Janet Jackson is
apologizing for her flashdance,
a last-minute stunt that went too far.
- The chairman of the
FCC concluded, quote,
"Clearly somebody had knowledge of it.
Clearly it was something
that was planned by someone," he said.
And then he said, quote,
"She probably got what
she was looking for,"
referring specifically to Janet Jackson.
So the FCC fines CBS for
like a half a million dollars
and this makes the CEO of CBS so angry
that he becomes fixated on
ruining Janet Jackson's life.
He made sure that she was blacklisted
from all of the major music
video networks like MTV and VH1
and all CBS-owned radio stations.
Now, radio stations, how quaint.
Remember, this is 2004.
There's no Spotify,
there's no Apple Music.
Radio stations were the place
where your music got out.
So was MTV, remember TRL?
Anyone remember TRL?
- At number one, closing out the week,
here's "Larger than
Life," the Backstreet Boys
(crowd cheering)
on TRL.
- Come on, TRL, Carson Daly?
I'm getting old.
It's fine.
I thought Carson Daly was pretty cool.
Janet Jackson was cut
off from all of this,
the lifeblood of her career
because she was thought
to have duped the country into
her perverse sexual stunt.
But wait a minute,
can we just rewatch
the video really quick?
Let's just, like, look
at who did what to whom.
What about this guy, the guy
who actually did the thing?
So here I am all these years
later, I'm a big boy now,
and I am a journalist.
I think about how words
are used to communicate
and inform the public.
The power of words, how we frame things.
I started to dive in to the
reporting from this time,
looking at hundreds of major newspapers
and how they covered what
happened at the Super Bowl,
this thing that became
known as Nipplegate.
If you do this, if you
really immerse yourself
in the news of the time,
how it was being discussed
and especially with a
little bit of hindsight
you can really learn a lot
about what really happened here.
So first off, let me
get this out of the way.
I delved into all of the investigations,
all of the evidence of whether
or not this was planned
from the FCC and the CBS
and all the people who were involved.
Was this an accident or
was this a publicity stunt?
Turns out, if you examine all the evidence
it's actually impossible to ascertain
a conclusive answer on
whether or not it was planned
by Janet Jackson or Justin
Timberlake or others.
You can make up your
own opinion about this,
but there are a few things
that I can say for certain
as I immerse myself in this stuff.
Number one, how the
incident was characterized.
Now listen, I like data.
Talking about how an
incident was characterized
is hard to put into data
unless you aggregate
a bunch of news articles and
look at the language they use
to talk about this event.
If you look at 200 news
articles from major newspapers
that covered this event,
in half of these articles
Justin Timberlake's involvement
is mentioned in passing.
It is not the focus of the article.
And even 1/3 of them, 1/3,
30% don't even mention
Justin Timberlake at all.
He's completely absent from
1/3 of these 200 articles.
Sorry, can we just rewind,
watch the video again?
Can we just watch it one more time.
So this happened and 33% of the articles
didn't mention this guy.
Wait, what, why not?
If you're a reporter and
you say, this happened
you should mention who did the thing.
Number two is the importance of language.
Language, language, language.
The words you use, the syntax you use
to construct your sentence matters.
And I know this, I know this for a fact
because I do this every day.
I sit at a computer and
I construct language
to communicate ideas.
So this, this is my sweet
spot, and I have a lot to say.
I'm looking at some of these
articles from the 2004 incident
and the language that is used
to describe what happened,
which again, is very important
especially in a pre-visual
web video internet age,
the language you use is very important.
"The New York Times," the
reputable "New York Times"
described the incident as,
Janet Jackson's breast-baring fiasco.
Another article framed this
as, Janet Jackson, quote,
flashed one breast in front
of the largest television
audience of the year
in the Super Bowl halftime show.
In normal English syntax you
have an agent, you have a verb,
and you usually have an object,
something that happened.
So some person or something
does, verbs, something else.
In this case, Janet Jackson was the agent.
She flashed her breast
in front of the largest
audience of the year.
No mention of anyone else.
"Washington Post," 2004, quote,
what Janet Jackson did was bizarre,
deliberately flopping out
of her costume like that.
The syntax, the lack of any other agent,
any other actionable person in this scene,
that frames this event in very clear terms
for a reader to decide
who's to blame here.
A lot of this reporting
turns Justin Timberlake,
the guy who actually pulled the breast cup
off of Janet Jackson's
clothing into the victim.
"The Boston Globe" says that, quote,
Justin Timberlake reached over
to that infamous right breast
belonging to Janet Jackson.
Reached over to that
infamous right breast.
Like the breast was inherently infamous.
It was just waiting for
innocent Justin Timberlake
to like, stumble into
the trap, (scoffs) what?
How can a breast be infamous?
Can somebody like, describe, like?
Comment below, how can
a breast be infamous?
These reports frame Janet
Jackson as the provoker
and Justin Timberlake as
the innocent bystander
being lured into the trap.
- All the emphasis was put on me.
- Mm-hmm.
- Not on Justin.
- Language matters.
I'm not just nitpicking
little teeny, tiny words here.
This is how you frame something.
As a journalist reporting
the facts is a process
of deciding what language you use
and what facts you choose to include.
The language used here
clearly pushes the
audience in one direction.
I mean, do you disagree?
Like, I'm sorry, am I being totally
misinterpreting here of this?
I'm trying to give the most
honest and generous read
to all of this and really
try to see it clearly,
and this is what it says
to me very, very clearly
from a data perspective.
I am looking at a lot of articles.
Okay, our third takeaway is,
who felt the fallout from this?
Whose career got F'd up?
Janet Jackson, not Justin Timberlake.
There was a dog-pile onto
Janet Jackson, blacklisting her
from the radio, from MTV, from VH1.
Meanwhile Justin Timberlake
skirted by basically unscathed.
In all of the interviews,
Janet is so apologetic
and ashamed and embarrassed
while Justin is sort of just like...
- Hey man, we love giving
y'all something to talk about.
- His career wasn't really touched by this
even though he's the guy who did this.
Janet, on the other hand,
became the most viral
thing in internet history.
And I'm not just being hyperbolic there.
This is considered the most-searched event
in the history of the internet.
And the search is Janet
Jackson exposing her breast.
It's not Justin Timberlake
ripping off a piece of clothing.
That is not the search.
The search is Janet Jackson.
Okay, my last takeaway, and
this is the one that like,
I don't really understand
and I want to have a
better understanding of
and I'm actually left a little
bit confused which is that
humans love this stuff, humans love it.
Our brain, for some reason, is predisposed
to love and fixate and just
devour this sort of content.
It's human psychology at its
most basic and predictable form
and I don't really understand why.
Let's remember the setting.
This is 2004, early 2004.
It's an election year.
George Bush is up for election.
A few months earlier George
Bush and his administration
had led us into a war in Iraq which,
as I've covered in previous videos,
was largely a war of choice.
And now our taxpayer money is being used
to wage a war halfway around the world
looking for fake WMDs and yet this,
this half a second of an exposed breast
was the epicenter of our attention.
This is what mattered.
This is what warranted discussion
and congressional hearings
and tons of conversation.
This woman and her body and her behavior.
- [Reporter] What part of the Super Bowl
did you like the best,
the halftime or the game?
(onlookers laughing)
- I'm not trying to be
the woke police here.
I'm not trying to convince you of anything
other than what I am seeing
and what I am finding
as I look at this with clear perspective
and with some understanding of
how language and media works
now that I've lived a little bit of life.
If I'm missing something, let me know.
But let me be clear about something.
This wasn't an isolated incident.
This sort of biased coverage and scrutiny
wasn't new in 2004 and
it certainly didn't stop.
I remember when I first
started working at Vox.
We would have these
meetings and discussions
about the YouTube comments.
And I was publishing stuff on YouTube.
I was showing my face
more and we were growing
and it was exciting and I
loved to read the comments
and be like, whoa, look
at all this excitement
around the work we're doing.
I was sort of naive and confused at first
because I would put a video up
and get all these cool comments.
Wow, this guy's traveling
the world, it's super cool.
And then I would read the comments
any time we would put up a video
where a woman, a female was the host.
The comments were always
so much more active
and not with discussion about the video
but about the host herself.
Her voice, her hair, her clothing.
I'm married to somebody who
makes videos for the internet.
I see every comment that comes in.
I see what you say to her
versus what you say to me.
It's as predictable as
my children's behavior.
It is like a law of
nature that the comments
on her videos will focus so
much on her touching her neck
or the voice she's using
or her interrupting me.
It's like so predictable,
it's like so simple, almost.
What is it?
Why do we love to shine
a spotlight on women
and analyze and talk
about what they look like
and how they behave?
- Now, that's almost
malfunctioning, isn't it?
(audience laughing)
(laughing)
Oh, wow.
Man, you, very nice.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- By the way, you smell wonderful.
- We just do, like,
there's just something
inside of us that does that.
If you're resistant to this,
I want to hear from you.
What's the counterpoint to this?
I'm seeing all this stuff.
I'm not just coming with this
'cause this is cool and culturally trendy.
I am seeing this in the data.
I've seen this over years and years
of observing mass human behavior
with tens of thousands of data points.
This is my conclusion, language matters
and for some reason in our society
our language around women is
very predictably scrutinizing
and focused on behavior
and voice and appearance.
That, to me is a fact
that I'm willing to just say very clearly.
And the Janet Jackson fiasco isn't about
whether or not it was a
conspiracy or publicity stunt.
You can have your opinions on that.
But what's clear to me
is that in this instance
and in many other instances,
it's a horribly predictable outcome.
Same old story, and frankly, I
find it slightly embarrassing
and unfortunate that it takes
me looking through the data
and reading loads of comments
to convince me that this is real.
It's almost like proof that
this is a deep part of my
and all of our psychologies.
Okay, that's all I've got.
(sighs)
Thank you, Squarespace,
for sponsoring this video.
Squarespace is an all-in-one
platform where you can go
and build an online presence
for whatever you want
whether it is a portfolio or
it is a shop or it is just
a personal place to have
your corner of the internet.
You don't need to know code.
You just need to have something to say
and a desire to put it on the internet.
So they have templates,
they have email marketing,
they have SEO, they have
integration with social platforms.
They sort of just have
it all in this one place.
It's very easy to use.
Because they sponsored
this video you can get 10%
off your first purchase
whether it's a domain name,
you want a custom domain
or it's hosting space
so that you can host a website.
You can get 10% off if you go
to squarespace.com/johnnyharris.
The link is the description.
If you click that link it
helps support this channel,
but it also gets you that discount.
Okay, that's all I've got.
Have a good day everybody.
(chair clinking)
(grunts) Come on.
(groans) Heavens.
Okay, I have all these papers.